[Musique]
bienvenue à nasrou bonjour Merci de
votre invitation alors vous êtes
vice-président du conseil régional vous
êtes élu de d'opposition à à trappe et
vous vous présentez comme candidat à la
présidence de la fédération LR des
ivelines puisque Pierre Bédier qui était
Président cède sa sa place alors on
avait reçu ici votre concurrent si je
peux dire Philippe benasa puisque vous
êtes deux deux candidats les élections
auront lieu le 26 et 27 novembre en
ligne tout à fait c'est un vote en ligne
pour les adhérents LR des Yvelines alors
c'est vous qui avez annoncé le premier
votre candidature à cette présidence
Philippe benassa est venu par la suite
alors je quand il est venu ici il nous
avait dit mais moi je proposé qu'on au
fond que je commence et puis qu'il
prenneent ma suite euh c'est vrai qu'il
vous a proposé ça moi quand j'ai fait
cette candidature je l'ai fait pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que j'ai considéré
qu'il fallait absolument qu'on refonde
la droite que le travail à faire était
colossal et que l'idée qu'on pouvait
continuer comme avant sans rien changer
est une idée suicidaire pour la droite
qui va disparaître si on ne se
renouvelle pas et si on ne va pas au
bout d'un certain nombre de convictions
et donc j'ai été absolument tout le
monde y compris Philippe benasaya et
vraiment tous tous les grands élus de de
notre département pour leur présenter ma
démarche et j'ai tout de suite eu
beaucoup de soutien je souhaitais aussi
travailler avec tout le monde et je vous
le dis très simplement au lendemain de
cette élection si je suis élu je
travaillerai naturellement avec
absolument tout le monde d'accord
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui vous réunit
après tout vous êtes présenté ensemble
dans la 11e circonscription des des
éivelines au législatives lui comme
candidat et vous comme suppléant et vous
avez été élu hein donc vous avez déjà
travaillé ensemble alors qu'est-ce qui
vous unit qu'est-ce qui vous distingue
je pas dire qu'il vous sépare qui vous
distingue oui parce que moi je n'ai pas
d'adversaire dans ma famille politique
je considère qu'aujourd'hui vu l'état du
pays on a besoin d'une droite qui soit
courageuse qui aille au bout d'un
certain nombre de convictions qu'il y
arrête de d'être dans l'eau tiède ou de
se cacher derrière son petit doigt et et
et il faut qu'on se renouvelle et donc
c'est pour cela que je porte cette
candidature avec beaucoup de soutien
avec quelqu'un comme François Xavier
bami dans ce départ ement qui pour moi
est vraiment quelqu'un qui incarne et
bien le courage politique et je crois
qu'on a besoin de courage
politique Philippe Benasser vous avez
raison de le dire on se connaît bien
quand on a voulu tous les deux être
candidats aux élections législatives en
2020 je j'avais fait le choix de me
retirer et de le soutenir et c'est ainsi
que nous avons gagné et donc je souhaite
moi continuer à rassembler très
largement parce que le travail qui nous
attend est un travail dans lequel on ne
peut pas se permettre les divisions
stériles les querelles d'g les vieilles
guerres du passé que que qu'on ne doit
pas rejouer et donc moi de mon côté je
garderai jusqu'au bout cette ligne de
conduite durant cette élection interne
parce que encore une fois on a besoin
pour le pays pour la France de
reconstruire une vraie droite qui soit
courageuse alors on va écouter un petit
extrait de ce que nous disait Philippe
benasaya qui parlait au fond de son
expérience et peut-être en creux si je
peux dire de votre inexpérience on
l'écoute puis vous vous vous réagissez
moi je pars d'un principe très
rapidement même si on en a déjà parlé
que il faut à la fois du renouvellement
comme je l'ai dis mais aussi de
l'expérience voilà j'ai fait basculer
une ville j'ai fait pasasculer une
circonscription j'ai fait basculer un
canton je pense que cette cette
expérience de terrain est utile pour les
républicains aujourd'hui et puis
également il faut aussi ce que j'ai dit
renouveler de font en comble la maison
je pas dit qu'elle était en ruine mais
elle elle portait une histoire
maintenant je pense qu'il faut
maintenant porter un avenir et porter
cet avenir là maintenant en matière de
communication en matière de militantisme
et en matière de de contenu aussi avec
des thématiques importantes comme
l'environnement que l'on a tendance de
temps en temps à oublier voà voà votre
réaction il dit voilà moi j'ai j'ai j'ai
été élu dans une ville j'ai fait
basculer une majorité j'ai fait basculer
une majorité dans législative j'ai
l'expérience on a tous nos parcours nos
expériences moi j'ai mené des combats
que certains ont considéré
particulièrement courageux à traape à
trap j'ai contribué à faire basculer
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvel un
siège près en 2014 après 42 années de
domination de la gauche j'ai contribué à
faire basculer le canton de trappe qui a
é également basculé qui a également
basculé en 2015 j'ai contribué à faire
basculer la région où je suis élu depuis
8 ans où j'ai occupé à peu près toutes
les fonctions possibles de président de
groupe de premier vice-président de
vice-président et donc on a chacun nos
expériences ce que je veux dire c'est
que cette idée qu'on peut simplement
être dans la continuité me paraît être
une idée suicidaire et c'est peut-être
là où j'ai une divergence je vous donne
un exemple moi j'ai regretté que durant
les élections précédentes on est investi
au nom de LR des candidats qui sont en
réalité des candidats de la République
en marche je pense que c'est une erreur
parce que ça contribue à à la confusion
du débat public vous par exemple au aux
élections départementales par exemple
aux élections départementales je pense
que nous aurions dû choisir toujours et
c'est en tout cas ce que je ferais des
candidats qui pent fièrement nos
couleurs nos valeurs qui ne se cachent
pas plutôt que d'être dans des accords
qui toujours se retournent contre nous
parce qu'ensuite vous avez des des gens
qui sont investis qui sont élus avec nos
couleurs et qui votent contre nous aux
élections nationales on peut citer n par
exemple je vousis Jean-Baptiste à
Monique euh qui est qui est maire de
Villepreux euh qui est qui est président
du
modemblin il est dans la majorité euh au
conseil départemental et c'est vrai
qu'il votent pas forcément comme vous
aux élections nationales c'est c'est ça
que vous voulez dire en gros euh
jeallais plutôt prendre l'exemple du
maire du chaîné qui avait battu notre
candidat et qui se retrouve
effectivement avec l'étiquette LR élu
ensuite au département comment
voulez-vous que des militants s'y
retrouve réadhère vous savez on avait 12
députés on en a plus que zéro
aujourd'hui on avait 12000 adhérents on
est descendu à moins de 1000 quand j'ai
lancé ma campagne et aujourd'hui on est
un peu plus nombreux parce qu'on est
allé réveiller on est allé chercher tout
le monde et c'est ce que je veux faire
mais je veux le faire dans la clarteté
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est bien
de rassembler mais il faut rassembler
autour de vraies convictions et autour
de quelque chose qui soit clair et
lisible pour les Français sinon il se
détourneront de nous comme ils se sont
détournés de la droite aujourd'hui
justement vous parliez de de la
situation de de LR dans ce département
euh ça a été le grand parti au fond de
de de ce département avec alors c reste
toujours au niveau des villes au niveau
des cantons ça ne l'est plus au niveau
national puisque vous aviez des députés
vous aviez encore deux en 2 22 là ils
ont tous été battus dès le premier tour
euh est-ce que au fond il y a il y a pas
une différence c'est dire que les partis
classiques la LR ou le le Parti
socialiste Contin continuent à être très
présents dans les territoires ils ne
sont plus au plan national et il y a au
plan national des nouvelles forces comme
Renaissance comme LFI qui qui tiennent
le le haut du pavé si je veux dire
est-ce qu'on n pas comment vous
expliquez cette cette différence moi je
pense que cette idée que le National et
le local sont décorrélés est une
mauvaise idée c'est une fausse idée
c'est peut être vrai un moment mais je
pense que tôt ou tard on est rattrapé
par le National et c'est pour ça que je
donner l'exemple et bien de cette clarté
qu' vous avez peur que ce qui se passe
sur la nationale se passe aussi dans les
territoires c'est ça bien sûr vous voyez
par exemple que le le la bataille
culturelle que l'on doit mener par
rapport à ce que moi j'appelle l'extrême
gauche par exemple à la France insoumise
et bien tôt ou tard dans des élections
municipales on voit que leur score aussi
progressent on voit que sur certaines
villes ils sont de devenu hégémonique
parce qu'on les a laissé aussi au
National au National développer leurs
idées être présent sur les médias être
présent sur les réseaux sociaux et
surtous les écrans de nos jeunes alors
que nous nous avions disparu nous ne
leur portions plus aucune contradiction
et vous voyez que même dans les
élections locales on retrouve à nouveau
ces forces-là qui finissent par émerger
sur un certain nombre de quartiers de
territoirees on ne peut jamais
décorréler les deux de la même manière
depuis qu'on a investi des candidats qui
ne sont pas de notre famille politique
et qui soutiennent au National d'autres
idées et bien on recule dans toutes les
élections nous n'avons fait que reculer
on a besoin de clarté on a besoin de
courage on a besoin d'une droite qui
s'assume clairement au local comme au
National donc vous dites voilà ce qui ce
qui s'est passé aux élections nationales
au présidentiel au législatives ça peut
aussi arriver dans les mairies dans les
dans les territoires dans dans les
canton si on si on change pas un peu le
ENF la façon de de de de faire cette
politique ou de mener parti et si on se
retrou pas les manches effectivement
vous l'avez vu peut-être durant cette
campagne moi j'ai fait énormément de
réunions publiques j'ai été absolument
partout dans les ivelines avec des
invités qui sont venus sur le fond on a
fait une réunion dédiée à la question
environnementale à plaisir une sur la
ruralité à Houdan on a travaillé à peu
près tous les thèmes il y en aura
d'autres qui vont venir j'ai thba de
mbrial qui va venir nous parler de ces
sujets malheureusement d'actualité de
radicalisation Frédéric pchnard va
également venir nous parler est avocat
et c'est lui qui avit défendu les
victimes de de cet horrible attentat de
Monville hein exactement et vous voyez
qu'on a donc la chance d'avoir des
experts des talents dans notre famille
politique qui qu'on
Arve police nationale il va nous parler
de sécurité parce qu'il faut aussi qu'on
forme Vè au cons conseil régional tout à
fait mais vous voyez il faut qu'on forme
nos militants on a plus mené
suffisamment cette bataille culturelle
on a un travail effectivement de
communication mais aussi de formation à
faire et nos militants nos adhérants ont
le droit à une vie militante dynamique
où il se passe très régulièrement des
choses partout dans tous les territoires
des Yvelines c'est comme ça qu'on arrive
à recréer un appareil qui ensuite peut
préparer les échéances municipales
européennes puis je juste le dire on
aura peut-être des législatives
anticiper ah on va en parler tout à
l'heure parce il faut qu' se prépareut
parce que la motion de censure oui çait
peut-être sur la loi sur l'immigration
euh il y a il y a quand même une crise
des partis politiques ils ont structuré
la la la la vie de la République
notamment de la la 5e République avec
ces de grandes forces la droite la
gauche on voit aujourd'hui qu' y a
peut-être moins de bout du militantisme
qui a peut-être d'autres façons de
militer plus avec les réseaux sociaux
plus avec les internets comment on peut
répondre justement à à ce qui est
évident c'està dire la crise des partis
alors je vous l'ai dit d'abord par de la
clarté on a souent des messages
politiques forts simples courageux et je
pense que tout ce qui est dans l'ambigué
et bien est condamné à disparaître parce
que les gens ont besoin de d'y voir
clair et je crois qu'à droite peut-être
nous avons déçu voyez je je j'assume
dans cette campagne interne de dire que
peut-être nous n'avons pas toujours été
à la hauteur ou nous n'avons pas
toujours été au bout d'un certain nombre
d'idées peut-être même avons-nous été en
soumission intellectuelle sur certains
thèmes nous nous sommes laissés imposer
des thèmes et des façons de voir le
monde qui ne sont pas les nôtres et
alors que les Français attendaient autre
chose et donc moi j'essaie de prendre ma
part dans ce travail-là au sein de la
nouvelle direction nationale des
républicains avec Eric cotti avec Bruno
rotaillot avec Olivier marlex avec
François Xavier bami avec d'autres on
fait tout ce travail-là de
redynamisation dont on a besoin de
renouvellement aussi de notre logiciel
et puis et puis et puis de communication
parce que cette bataille culturelle elle
est importante et c'est uniquement comme
cela qu'on peut retrouver des adhérents
voyez dans cette campagne on est allé
chercher des anciens adhérant desess on
leur a expliqué que nous voilà ce que
nous voulait faire euh sur tel thème
quelles idées on voulait porter quelle
est la ligne politique qu'on pensait
être la bonne pour le pays et quels sont
les outils je vous ai parlé de formation
je vous ai parlé de communication je
vous ai parlé d'une vie militante
dynamique qu'on veut mettre en œuvre
pour qu'ils puissent à nouveau retrouver
leur place au sein d'une grande famille
politique de droite comme on a pu en
connaître dans ce département il y a une
quinzaine d'années c'est ce que vous
dites d'ailleurs dans votre profession
de de de foi de candidat la droite a
souvent été en soumission intellectuelle
j'ai l'intime conviction que c'est
précisément parce que nous avons renoncé
à défendre clairement nos idées et vous
dites aussi notautre pays n' jamais eu
autant besoin d'une politique de droite
pourquoi moi je ne veux pas assister en
spectateur au déclin de mon pays et je
ne veux pas me réveill en 2027 persuadé
voilà qu'il y a un déclin ah oui je
pense que beaucoup de Français le voient
sur la sécurité sur l'état de nos
finances publique sur l'état de
l'hôpital sur l'état de l'école de
l'éducation nationale qui s'est
totalement effondré il y a beaucoup de
choses il y a beaucoup d'indicateurs
aujourd'hui qui sont très préoccupant on
a le sentiment qu'il y a un vrai
délitement et moi je ne veux pas
assistant spectateur à cela et je ne
veux pas me réveiller en 2027 avec un
face à face entre Marine Le Pen et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà et d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas lequel des deux gagnerait
en réalité réellement ce face à face ce
que je sais par contre c'est qu'il n'y a
que la droite qui peut déjouer ce
pronostic et qui peut faire en sorte que
sur la sécurité sur la maîtrise des flux
migratoires sur la maîtrise de la
dépense publique sur la revalorisation
du travail il n'y a que la droite qui
peut proposer des solutions concrètes à
condition qu'elle s'assume et qu'elle
soit courageuse dans les propositions
qu'elle fait parce que l'état du pays de
mon point de vue nécessite beaucoup de
courage beaucoup plus de courage que en
a aujourd'hui ce gouvernement par
exemple mais quand il y a parce qu'on
peut parler aussi enfin avec les les les
les gens qui comme vous disent voilà on
a besoin de la droite il faut que l'air
s'affirme comme comme un parti de droite
mais l'un des reproches qu'on vous fait
c'est que vous marchez un peu sur les
les terres du rassemblement national en
faisant ça et que on dit toujours voilà
les les gens préfèrent l'original à la
copie et si la droite républicaine se
droitise elle va plutôt favoriser le le
rassemblement national que que récupérer
les les fruits de de cette droitisation
bon d'abord je n'ai pas le sentiment que
le rassemblement national ait besoin
aujourd'hui que la droite agisse d'une
manière ou d'une autre pour se renforcer
et je considère que si le rassemblement
national se renforce c'est qu'en réalité
les autres partis ne proposent pas des
solutions suffisamment claires et
suffisamment courageuses par rapport à
l'état du pays et donc moi je ne me
positionne pas par rapport à ce que
disent les autres partis politiques je
ne défends pas des segments de marché je
ne crois pas qu'il fallit qu'on soit
dans des positionnements électoraux ou
des combinaisons des accords de boutiqu
des stratégies de positionnement
marketing je crois qu'on en meurt de ça
je crois que la vie politique de ce pays
meurt de ces stratégies de court terme
et d'affichage et de communication je
vous dis il faut qu'à droite on dise ce
qu'on pense bon pour le pays et ça m'est
complètement régal de savoir si le
rassemblé national ou Emmanuel Macron
dit la même chose tant que je pense que
c'est ce qui est bon pour le pays si je
vous dis qu'il faut qu'on remette une
réponse pénale à la hauteur parce qu'on
a un sujet dans notre pays de
délinquence qui n'est pas traité de
peine de prison non exécuté je me moque
totalement de savoir qui d'autre le dit
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on le fasse
parce que le pays on a besoin parce
qu'un pays où il n'y a pas d'ordre un
pays où la loi n'est pas respectée est
un pays qui ne peut pas tenir et dont la
cohésion est à terme menacée c'est ça
que je pense et je ne me positionne pas
par rapport aux autres aux autres partis
politiques on voit quand même qu'il y a
de tendances possibles enfin pour pour
la droite républicaine il y a il y a la
tradition
chirakienne une barrière infranchissable
entre la droite républicaine et et le
l'extrême droite ou la droite populiste
je sais pas comment il faut l'appeler en
tout cas le rblan National et puis il y
a il y a ceux qui se disent au fond et
et je sais pas Eric Coti avait dit par
exemple s'il y avait un combat Zemour
Macron je voterai pour Zemour donc
d'autres qui disent peut-être
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il faut faire
une droite nationale plus plus large
est-ce que là-dessus il faut être à
votre avis très clair faut dire non il y
aura jamais d'accord avec avec la droite
extrême ou est-ce que vous laissez les
portes ouvertes non mais là aussi vous
me demandez toujours en permanence de me
positionner par rapport aux et aux
autres et je vais vous dire une chose le
problème aujourd'hui il n'est pas
celui-là il est qu'on a un président de
la République qui s'est fait passer pour
un président de la République de droite
qui du coup a installé un face- à
faceace entre lui et les extrêmes et et
a fait monter finalement il compris
l'extrême gauche qui est en réalité très
puissante dans notre pays ce que je vois
moi c'est que aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
sorte que les masques tombent et qu'on
sorte de cette de cette opération de
magie de de de prtigateur qu' a mené
Emmanuel Macron nous essayons de nous
expliquer que la politique ILM est une
politique de droite c'est ça aujourd'hui
qui nous a coûté cher c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que nous ne sommes plus
audibles alors qu'il est en échec sur la
sécurité je l'ai dit sur la maîtrise du
FL migratoire qu'il a accumulé 700
milliards de dettes que jamais on AP C
TR mais mais parce que parce qu'on a
traditionnellement on considère que la
droite et bien est soucieuse de ces
thèml système éducatif aussi enfin le
niveau scolaire s'est totalement
effondré l'autorité a disparu ça date
pas de mac non non il y a des problèmes
qui datent d'avant lui je suis a voilà
il y a aussi des choses qui arrivent
quand on gouverne qui viennent de loin
aussi oui mais il y a aussi on parlera
de l'immigration tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que si si on regarde au fond il y a
eu beaucoup de discours sur
l'immigration même du de Chirac de
pasqui mais au fond personne n'a jamais
fait grand-chose alors on pourra en
parler parler mais ce que je vous dire
simplement c'est qu'on arrête de me dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui metne la
politique de droite dans le pays a
besoin ça n'est pas vrai c'est un mythe
et donc vous me demandez des accords des
positionnements sur des votes de second
tour moi ce que je sais c'est que si on
n pas une offre politique de droite on
aura pas la question de savoir avec qui
on va s on va voir la question d'avoir
Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
second tour en 2027 et ce que je veux
éviter mais pourquoi parce que d'abord
ils ont le même programme économique
vous juste à le signaler hein la
retraite à 60 ans j'en passe et bien
d'autres choses qui sont totalement
irréalistes et dont on n pas les moyens
aujourd'hui qui coulerait davantage
encore le pays et puis je parle même pas
des entreprises la question des charges
enfin bon de la question de l'emploi qui
serait vraiment sacrifié dans les
programmes économique de ces de de
l'extrême gauche mais que
malheureusement le rassemblement
national reprend mais ce que je veux
vous dire très clairement c'est qu'on a
besoin d'une droite autonome qui arrive
à à à proposer autre chose à ce pays qui
ne soit ni le macronisme ni ni des voies
et bien notamment celle de l'extrême
gauche parce que moi je me méfie
vraiment beaucoup de la du point
l'extrême gauche dans les chqu polique
l'interv d'illeur que vous avez fait
dans dans fig vous en parlez beaucoup
mais vous vous pensez que dans un
paysage politique fracturé un un seul
mouvement peut peut peut avoir une
majorité peut sans alliance mais oui je
le pense et je pense que d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec Emmanuel
Macron quand les Français ont choisi et
de le faire élire et de lui donner une
majorité je vous rappelle il y avait une
alliance de centristes de il y a des
gens de droite qui sont venus il y a des
gens de gauche qui sont venus il y a il
y a eu quand même des des voilà un
regroupement euh est-ce que aujourd'hui
un parti seul peut avoir une majorité
vous pensez euh ah oui je l'air pour
pour voilà vous pensez que peut avoir
une majorité un président et une
majorité bah en tout cas j'y crois
beaucoup plus que des alliances contre
nature d'accord voyez vous me parlez on
parlait desord Emmanuel Macron sur la
question du nucléaire nous sommes la
seul famille politique et j'aimerais
qu'on le dise qu'on le valorise là aussi
il faudrait qu'on soit déjà sur les
marchés avec d'un tracte àer rappeler à
tout le monde que c'est grâce à nous que
que le nucléaire existé puis surtout
qu'on l' toujours défendu que notre main
n'a jamais tremblé que notre parole n'a
jamais varié sur la question du
nucléaire euh toutes les autres familles
politiques Emmanuel Macron en tête et
bien se sont détournés du nucléaire
Emmanuel Macron l'a affaibli voilà un
beau sujet avec qui vous voulez vous
allier sur cette questionl stratégique
essentielle pour pour pour la France il
faut dire s vous là mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui je crois que une grande
grande majorité des des Français sont
favorables au nucléaire parce que les
les événems que les factures
d'électricité sen absolument absolument
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a
quelques années en arrière les
écologistes étaient contre il voilà il y
avait même il y avait même l'idée qu'il
faudrait sortir un jour du nucléire qui
était assez répandu ils avaient réussi à
imposer ces écologistes là que moi
j'appelle des idéologues parce que pour
moi ils n'ont rien d'olog une victoire
culturelle comme vous exctement ils ont
mené cette bataille culturelle et ils
ont gagné ils ont obtenu de François
Hollande puis d'Emmanuel Macron le
démentantellement de notre filière
nucléaire et en face d'ailleurs Marine
Le Pen elle-même expliquait en 2017 que
leur nucléaire étaé probablement
dangereux donc vous voyez et nous nous
n'avons jamais varié et donc je pense
qu'on a besoin de cette droite là et que
elle est en capacité de regagner la
confiance des Français à condition
qu'elle arrête de se cacher derrière son
petit doigt qu'elle arrête d'être
uniquement dans des combinaisons dans
des accords d'appareil à chercher la
bonne alliance et je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens à droite aujourd'hui
qui attendent une droite courageuse qui
va au bout d'un certain nombre d'idées
et qui refait à nouveau ce travail quand
vousez alors un de vos collègues
puisqu'il est président de Région
l'urvoqué euh mais qui est aussi
peut-être un le le le candidat enfin qui
sera peut-être le candidat LR enfin on
verra en 2027 euh qui dans sa région
renonce au au aux zânes c'està dire que
qui est un des moyens de de de la
transition écologique et de la lutte
contre le réchauffement du climat ou qui
est favorable au aux technologies de
reconnaissance faciales qui sont quand
même euh des technologies qui ont plutôt
été utilisées en Chine ou dans des pays
totalitaires euh vous pensez que c'est
un bon signe ou pas bah ce que je pense
c'est que cette question de l'écologie
elle est évidemment importante il faut
que à droite on se la réapproprie moi je
vous rappelle que c'est la droite qui
cré le ministère de l'Environnement que
les équilibres préservation des
équilibres c'est une manière de voir le
monde non maison a été vraiment les
premiers écologistes fr de
l'environnement je crois mais on n pas
obligé d'être dans l'écologie punitive
on n'est pas obligé de se laisser dicter
nos thèmes on n'est pas obligé de céder
à Europe Écologie Les Verts qui parfois
fait de la lutte des classes à travers
l'écologie qui n'est pas réellement dans
l'écologie c'est pour ça je vous l'i dit
on a fait réunion à plaisir avec un
jeune député LR de 30 ans qui s'appelle
Antoine Vermorel marquez qui est
spécialisé député de la Loire spécialisé
sur les questions d'écologie et qui lui
a une approche bien de droite de ces
questions là et on a beaucoup de choses
à dire dans nos collectivités on fait
beaucoup en matière d'écologie en
matière de transition écologique et
compris en Île de France à la région
mais dans nos maies dans ce département
région il beaucoup de et ben il faut
qu'on le valorise il faut qu'on le
valorise mais donc cette question du zan
en réalité c'est une question difficile
parce que la loi aujourd'hui nous impose
cette trajectoire et on peut le
comprendre pour des raisons mais ça a
des conséquences qui doivent être prise
en compte on ne peut pas demander des
territoires mais bien sûr de toute façon
nos maires sont soumis à tellement
d'injonctions contradictoires il ne faut
plus artificialiser sols mais il faut
construire du logement alors bon courage
donc il faut qu'on tienne des
entreprises exactement j'étais à houd
avec Jean-Marie tard qui m'expliquait la
difficulté qu'il avait en ayant si peu
de de possibilité de construire dans un
territoire qui du comme le comme
le comme le veut Laurent
voquier en tout cas là où leurier c'est
qu'en zone rurale il faut qu'on puisse
et bien permettre des capacités de
développement sans que ça empiète sur
des terres agricoles sans être dans une
lecture si vous voulez stricte du c'est
ce qu'on essaie de faire en île-de-fance
on essaie de mettre de la souplesse par
exemple en faisant en sorte que déjà
chaque commune est au moins un hectare
et qu'ensuite on puisse transférer des
hectares d'un territoire à l'autre parce
qu'il y en a qui ont des besoins
d'autres en ont moins mais qu'on ait de
la souplesse et pas qu'on fiche
définitivement le développement de notre
pays parce que le reste du monde lui
continue son développement et donc on
n'est pas obligé d'être là aussi le pays
qui se met tout le temps des boulet au
pieds il faut qu'on fasse de l'écologie
il faut qu'on fe intelligemment B pour
en mot pour les gens qui le zan c'est
zéro artificialisation naturelle c'est
ça c'està dire que si on construit il
faut zéro artificialisation nette
c'est-àdire que voilà c'estàd que le
sold de des terrains qu'on prend et bien
est à zé en 2050 absolument et sur la
reconnaissance faciale parce que ça
c'est un vrai débat de de fond au fond
on va le voir parce que ce territoire va
accueillir beaucoup d'épreuves des Jeux
Olympiques il y a un impératif de
sécurité qui est est évident et que que
vous prenez d'ailleurs mais il y a il y
a aussi la liberté
individuelle et comment on arbitre là
entre les deux moi ce que je peux vous
dire là-dessus c'est que on laisse les
délinquants et les criminels utiliser
les meilleures technologies au monde et
nous on on s'en prive et on en prive nos
forces de l'ordre ça ne peut pas marcher
évidemment qu'il faut être souciux des
libertés individuelles évidemment que le
rôle de laakneil est par exemple un rôle
très important en matière de protection
des libertés individuelles des données
personnelles on est tous d'accord mais
aujourd'hui on est cap en capacit C de
faire la reconnaissance fatiale dans les
aéroports donc je vois pas très bien
pourquoi on le ferait dans les aéroports
on pourrait pas le faire ailleurs je
vous rappelle ce débat là il y a encore
10 ans il y a encore 5 ans la vidéo
protection était critiquée par certains
on les entend plus aujourd'hui tout à
gauche de l'chiquier politique était
farouchement opposé à mettre des caméras
dans les transports qui aujourd'hui est
compte le fait de mettre des caméras qui
pense encore que c'est liberticide on
nous disait la même chose des caméras
c'est liberticide et cetera nous on en
met dans les lycées à la demande des
établissements à la région Île-de-France
on en a mis plus de 3000 il y a encore 5
ans on nous insulter de tous les noms
pour le faire aujourd'hui on nous en
réclame et tout le monde est d'accord
donc je crois que la situation de
sécurité aujourd'hui de notre pays
nécessite qu'on se donne des outils moi
je ne suis absolument pas opposé à ce
qu'on utilise la reconnaissance faciale
pour reconnaître des individus dangereux
recherchés plutôt que d'avoir des gens
derrière les écran qui le font
manuellement parce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui mais il faut le faire
évidemment avec la main qui tremble en
encadrant très bien les choses sur le
plan des droits de la surveillance et du
contrôle mais je crois que se privé de
ce genre d'outil et bien ne va pas
malheureusement dans le sens de
l'histoire de toute façon c'est rare
qu'on se prive d'une technologie bien
sûr parce qu'elle sera utilisée par
d'autres ouis alors parlons d' alors
d'un sujet que vous avez abordé dans une
interview que vous avez faite il y a 3
jours dans dans le dans le
Figaro vous avez des mots très forts
vous dites la France n'est pas en train
de se fracturer mais de disparaître et
et vous parlez de
désassimilation est-ce que la situation
est aussi grave que vous le dites moi je
je crois qu'elle est grave et je crois
surtout qu'elle s'aggrave et euh on peut
toujours se dire le tableau n'est pas
aussi noir mais je ne veux pas que dans
quelques années on se rendre compte
qu'il est trop tard h et au rythme où
vont les choses si nous ne réagissons
pas je suis préoccupé ce que je vois moi
c'est que il y a des choses qui fondent
une société des valeurs communes une
culture commune des références communes
et que ça se délite voilà c'est ce que
je constate je constate qu'il y a un
délitement de ce qui fait qu'une société
peut tenir ensemble et ça passe parce
qu'il y a l'entrrisme d'un certain
nombre d'identitaires religieux il y a
l'influence aussi de la radicalisation
des de l'entrrisme des islamistes qui
ont un agenda politique sur
malheureusement certaines populations
qui essaient de les conduire vers une
lecture qui est contre la République est
contre la France c'est vraiment ce que
je constate et je je pense qu'on est
nombreux à le constater donc oui il y a
le constater dans des villes comme traap
enfin vous êtes par exemple ou
évidemment évidemment et ce n'est pas
simplement moi qui vous le dis vous
pouvez rencontrer beaucoup d'habitants
de trappe qui vous n diront que ils ont
le sentiment que ce qui faisait et bien
la vie en commun est en train de
disparaître que le fait religieux prend
le pas sur sur le fait national sur le
fait qu'on est forme d'abord une
communauté nationale je vous donne un
exemple à trappe il n'y a plus de
charcuterie depuis 2015 dans une ville
de 32000 habitants ça peut paraître
anecdotique vous pourvez me dire c'est
l'offre et la demande mais comment
voulez-vous qu'il y ait de la mixité
quand vous avez des gens qui n'ont plus
le sentiment qu'ils peuvent trouver dans
leur ville et bien une offre qui
s'adapte à eux et donc donc ces gens-là
partent ils partent et on concentre
ainsi et bien les mêmes populations qui
en plus ne sont pas en demande moi j'ai
beaucoup de trapiste de toute confession
qui vous disent qu'ils veulent de la
mixité qu'ils ne veulent pas être dans
espèce de getto identitaire où ils sont
constamment enfermés dans un discours de
radicalisation mais bien sûr mais oui
mais il y a des gensction oui mais il y
a des gens qui l'ont fait exprès il y a
des élus de gauche et d'extrême gauche
qui ont voulu concentrer les logements
sociaux dans les mêmes quartiers pour se
constituer à vie un électorat captif il
porte aujourd'hui une lourde
responsabilité dans ce repli identitaire
moi je ne veux pas de ce repli
identitaire je pense qu'il est une
menace parce qu'il conduit à avoir un
système de valeur parallèle sur notre
somme deux systèmes de valeur et tôt ou
tard ces systèmes de valeurs et bien pr
peuvent s'entrechoquer moi je ne le veux
pas je veux que retrouver de la cohésion
dans notre pays bah ça veut dire qu'on
doit réaffirmer ce que c'est que la
France quelles sont ses valeurs et que
tout le monde doit évidemment les
respecter se les approprier et aussi
qu'on doit donner une chance à chacun à
chacun pourvu que chaque cette personne
respecte les règles et adhère à ce récit
à ce destin commun je crois que c'est
fondamental et je crois que ça sera une
bataille importante dans les années à
venir et ce que vous dites donc il y a
cette situation en effet de de
regroupement de population et donc de
communautarisme dans dans certains
quartiers euh et mais vous pensez qu'il
y a quand on parle de islamisme parce
que vous soyons concret vous pensez
qu'il y a un une volonté de certaines
organisations je sa pas les Frères
musulmans peu importe enfin pour pour en
citer euh de combattre la République et
de d'avoir un vrai combat contre la
République ah ça me paraît évident je
pense qu'il y a des tentatives pour
tester aussi la
résistance je vous donne juste un
exemple cette question des abayas le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
choisi d'interdire les abayas écoutez
très bien je consid que c'est une tenue
qui n'a évidemment rien à faire au sein
de l'école de la républque alors il y a
eu très peu de débordement suite à
l'interdiction comme quoi quand on
réaffirme les règles et qu'on est
courageux et bien ça marche
contrairement à ce qu'on nous avait dit
mais par contre il fallait se demander
aussi comment on en est arrivé là
comment on en arrivé estce que des
milliers de nos jeunes se présentent à
l'entrée de nos établissements devant
l'école de la République dans des tenues
qui évidemment sont des tenues ou
communautaires ou religieuse peu importe
mais qui n'ont rien à faire au sein de
l'école de la République c'est
évidemment sous l'influence d'un certain
nombre de prédicateurs de de gens qui
sont présents sur les réseaux sociaux
dont certains sont très populaires et
qui diffusent ces idées-là et ils le
font avec un agenda politique et bien
pour créer précisément cette crispation
au sein de la société et nourrir ce
repli identitaire qui leur donne ensuite
et bien des des des militants à eux des
des émules des gens qui vont adhérer
ensuite à leur thèse qui vont être
radicalisés dans un discours de
confrontation avec la République mais
quel ser quel serait leur but de prendre
le pouvoir de mais je pense que je pense
que il y a des gens qui utilisent
effectivement le prétexte religieux pour
essayer de prendre le pouvoir sur les
esprits et et qui en ont fait leur fond
de commerce et les exemples sont très
nombreux vous en avez qui appellent
ouvertement à quitter la France à aller
vivre euh dans les pays d'origine il y
en a qui appellent parfois
malheureusement à tourner leurs armes
contre la France quand on a des des
individus isolés qui décident tout à
coup de passer à l'acte euh c'est pas
simplement qu'ils sont fous
déséquilibrés c'est qu'ils le font aussi
au nom d'une idéologie qui les amèent à
le faire et il y a des gens qui ont
cette agenda là de pousser et bien
certains malheureusement de nos jeunes
et bien à tourner leurs armes contre la
France il faut être fou pour ne pas le
voir et d'ailleurs il y a des études
très documentées là-dessus d'un certain
nombre d'intellectuels je pense à Gill
kppel par exemple bONJ
Florence lecl par exemple toutcoup
voilà notamment vous parlez des chcrique
le le halal c'est pas du tout religieux
c'est et donc il faut que nous on arrête
d'être naïf il faut qu'on arrête d'être
naïf et il faut qu'on qu'on défende
notre modèle qui est un modèle généreux
pourvu que les règles soient respectées
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je le
vois c'est comme ça je pense que la
droite doit le porter vous voyez je
pense que la droite a une responsabilité
immense sur ce thème-là face notment
pour qu' y il y a des il y a des des
gens qui ne voit pas le danger ou des
gens qui profitent de ce politiquement
de ce danger et qu'il faut l'affirmer
enfin et le combattre oui je pense que
ce danger d'abord est vu par beaucoup de
nos concitoyens on VO les enquêtes
d'opinion beaucoup de Françaises et de
Français sont convaincus qu'elle a une
vraie menace et je pense que cette
menace elle est elle est fondée mais je
pense qu'effectivement il y a notamment
à gauche à l'extrême gauche des gens qui
en ont fait un fond de commerce qui
nourisent qui tiennent des discours
quand même d'une grande ambiguïé d'une
grande compromission on le voit avec la
France insoumise avec ce qui se passe au
ProcheOrient mais même avant on l'a vu
par rapport à la police quand vous avez
des des des des des élus d'extrême
gauche qui vous expliquent que que le
policier finalement il est au même
niveau qu'un ant que la police est
systématiquement raciste et brutale ne
me dites pas que l'objectif c'est pas de
créer une confrontation de faire des
policier à nouveau une cible et de
nourrir et bien une haine une
détestation de la police dans une partie
de la population je crois que mais il il
y a eu des violences policières on peut
pas le le dire l'idée qu'il y a des
violences
systémiques l'idée qu'il y a des
violences systémiques est une idée
fausse quand on voit notre police par
rapport à toutes les police du monde ça
n'est pas vrai et c'est le corps le plus
contrôlé de notre pays ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il a pas parfois voàut av des
faut individu mais il y il y a aussi des
violences qu'on peut pas qui ont existé
oui mais il y a aussi 30000 refus
d'obtempérés tous les ans dans notre
pays c'est 30 fois plus qu'il y a 30 ans
30 fois plus ça veut dire que 30000 fois
par an il y a un individu qui refuse
d'obéir à un ordre donné par un policier
et vous vous étonnez que parfois il
puisse y avoir des des incidents ou des
ou des tragédies qui arrivent et la
réalité c'est que on a j'ai fait un
débat moi sur une une autre chaîne avec
Sandrine Rousseau qui m'expliquait
ouvertement que et bien c'était on é
autorisé à désobéir ou à ne pastempérer
à la police parce qu'on a cette
idéologie là qui est diffusée auprès de
notre jeunesse et c'est faux il faut
rappeler les principes élémentaires qui
font qu'une société peut tenir debout
sinon elle s'effondre et je crois
qu'elle aujourd'hui nous sommes à la
croisée des chemins parler de ce qui se
passe dans dans cette interview en
Israël et et c'est retombé en France
avec vous vous l'évoquiez avec justement
la fille qui ne veut pas dire que le has
c'est un mouvement terroriste euh vous
vous craignez euh il y a toujours ce
risque d'exportation euh du conflit dans
notamment dans les quartiers bah je je
je je crains surtout que on cède sur des
principes élémentaires et que du coup la
confrontation arrive parce qu'on a pas
su rappeler le bon sens le plus
élémentaire si on n pas capable de
qualifier de terroristes des actes qui
évidemment sont épouvantables sont une
abomination que rien jamais ne peut
justifier et ben oui on va aller à la
confrontation il faut avoir le courage
de le dire très clairement oui c'est du
terrorisme oui il faut le condamner et
j'en veux beaucoup à ces élus dira je
parle beaucoup de l'extrême gauche mais
parce que vous voyez comme ça son
emprise est puissante c'est parce qu'il
y a des élus qui ont pour vous c'est
l'extrême gauche he pour moi la France
insoumis c'est évidemment l'extrême
gauche oui quand on n'est pas capable de
dire que des attentats sont du
terrorisme et bien après ce qu'on a vécu
nous-même sur notre sol je pense que
effectivement on crée la dissension on
crée le séparatisme on nourrit la
confrontation potentiellement demain
dans certains quartiers et cette cause
palestinene elle a été instrumentalisée
pendant longtemp par par beaucoup d'élus
en France avec des vœux qui sont votés à
chaque fois il y a toujours eu hein
quand même des des gens qui soutenaient
la CA palestinienne des gens qui
soutenaient Israël je dire c'est alors
évidemment il il y a cette actualité
terrible qui qui vient là-dessus mais ça
ça a toujours cette fracture elle a
toujours existé quand même non ben on n
pas besoin nous les élus de nourrir
cette fracture et surtout on a par
contre besoin de dire d'une seule voix
que ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre en
Israël relève du terrorisme et si on
n'est pas capable de mettre cette ligne
rouge là de distinguer ce sujet-l du
reste et bien on crée sur notre sol des
conditions de la sécession et c'est ce
qui me fait peur et oui je vous le dis
l'extrême gauche la gauche la France
insoumise et une partie de l'chqu
politiqu de gauche tous leurs alliés
sont directement responsables
directement responsables de ce qui est
en train de se passer dans notre pays à
savoir qu'il a une partie de la
population minoritaire heureusement mais
importante qui a été abreuvée par une
idéologie qui tôt ou tard va nous
conduire à la confrontation et c'est ce
qui me préoccupe le plus comment vous
expliquez une évolution par exemple de
de quelqu'un comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui était République he laïque pendant
pendant
longtemps on peut penser que derrière
ces prises de position il y a aussi un
calcul politique mais visiblement si on
regarde les les les sondages ça marche
pas comment vous expliquez cette
évolution justement alors vous dites ça
marche pas moi je vous signale si vous
regardez le premier tour de la
présidentielle qu'il fait un très bon
score qui ne passe pas loin d'être au
second Tourou je veux dire des sondages
aujourd'hui sembl montrer qu'il est
qu'il est plutôt ob quoi d'accord
d'accord mais att trpe au premier tour
de la présidentielle il fait plus de 6 %
plus de 60
% stratégie électorale évidemment
évidemment le problème c'est qu'en
allant chercher ces voislà il les mène
vers un chemin qui est une impasse
absolue et qui est un chemin comme je
l'ai dit de confrontation avec le reste
du pays et c'est totalement criminel de
faire ça mais oui je pense que c'est par
électoralisme je ne crois pas que ce
soit simplement des dérapages je ne
crois pas que ce soit des des excès
personnels je crois que c'est une
stratégie d'un cynisme absolu et cette
stratégie là et bien il faut la
démasquer c'est pour cela que je
considère qu'à droite on a une bataille
culturelle à mener face à l'extrême
gauche dont l'emprise sur les esprits
est très puissante dans notre pays et
bien il faut qu'on déconstruise pour
reprendre un terme qui leurait cher
beaucoup de cette idéologie là en
rappelant aussi des choses qui sont du
bon sens élémentaires mais qu'on a pas
toujours su et bien affirmer clairement
parce que évidemment c'est tout de suite
taxé de tous les noms et cetera voilà
moi je on peut pas me soupçonner la
moindre compromission avec qui que ce
soit mais je veux dire très clairement
que si on n pas ce discours là de
défense de la France et de la République
dans notre pays et bien on va laisser le
ch libre à à à cet extrême gauche qui va
finir par déconstruire et bien y compris
y compris notre pays et ça je ne le veux
pas un un de vos amis François Xavi bami
parce que vous parlez enfin la la la la
droite républicaine parle beaucoup de
sécurité euh euh il dit dans une tribune
au fond si les lois françaises avaient
été enfin avait été appliqué euh ni
Samuel paatti ni Dominique Bernard ne ne
serait mort sous les coups de
terroristes vous pensez que c'est vrai
ça par d'abord d'abord souvent la loi a
été appliquée l'assassin de de de de de
ce professeur Dominique Bernard il on
pouvait pas l'expulser parce qu'il était
arrivé avant l'âge de 1 ans donc on
appliquit au fond les lois c'est
peut-être les lois qu'il faut changer
mais est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
une politique raisonnablement qui
pourrait empêcher au fond ces gens qui
se radicalisent et qui qui sont plutôt
isolés qui vont qui vont prendre une
cible comme ça comme c'est prof qui
était Samuel Patti ou Dominique Bernard
Patrice carmous le risque zéro n'existe
pas n'existera jamais mais François
Xavier Bellami a raison il y a quand
même des choses qu'on doit faire pour
minimiser ce risque et aujourd'hui nous
ne le faisons pas et il a raison de dire
que le sujet c'est l'application de la
loi quand vous avez des individus alors
c'est pas le cas effectivement pour la
tragédie d' race mais ça arrivait par le
passé qui sont sous ooctf et donc par
définition qui doivent quitter le
territoire qui sont censés être expulsés
qui ne le sont pas comme vous le savez
on expulse moins de 10 % des gens dont
on a décidé l'expulsion on est quand
même un pays formidable on décide qu'on
expulse quelqu'un et 9 fois sur 10 on
l'expulse pas pour tout un tas de
raisons pour tout un tas de raisons
complexes d'ailleurs oui ENF il y a 15
ans très complexe souv il y a 15 ans on
expé 45 % aujourd'hui on est passé sous
les 10 % donc il y a aussi des
responsabilités politiques à établir on
n pas obligé de dire toujours que tout
se vaut quand ce n'est pas le cas et
donc en l'occurrence si cet individu
passe à l'acte alors qu'il n'aurait pas
dû être présent sur le sol français
c'est une tragi qu'on aurait pu qu'on
aurait dû éviter et vous voyez si
François Xavier bami ou d'autres ne le
disent pas mais nos concitoyens vont
devenir fous parce qu'ils ne comprennent
plus pourquoi il ils élisent des gens et
qu' qui vent des lois sont avec nous il
y aurait pas eu ça quoi au gros mais
c'est pas ce que dit François bami il
vous dit qu'il faut qu'on ait le courage
d'aller au bout précisément des de
l'application des lois qu'on vote parce
qu'autrement on va avoir une
insurrection électorale autrement t tous
ceux qui nous disent attention les
extrêmes sont à nos portes et bien les
Français au bout d'un moment vont
vouloir vraiment des solutions beaucoup
plus radicales parce qu'ils n'en peuvent
plus de constater l'IMP puissance
publique comment voulez-vous comprendre
qu'on vote des lois qu'un individu est
censé être expulsé et que on découvre
quelques semaines après qu'il passe à
l'acte et qu'il et qu'il se rend
coupable d'un crime absolument terrible
comment voulez-vous le comprendre quelle
est la réaction d'un citoyen honnête en
assistant à cela qui a voté pour des
élus qui sont sensé faire appliquer les
lois et voter des lois je suis désolé on
a le devoir de réagir on a le devoir on
a un devoir de résultat voilà c'est
simplement ça que je vous dis on peut
pas rester dans cette impuissance
publique qui nourrit toutes les
démagogies et tous les populismes
puisquon parlait de françoisav l'ami
vous vous souhaitez qu'il mène la liste
des européennes oui moi je le souhaite
je le soutiens je pense que il a fait un
travail formidable au Parlement européen
qu'il a un bilan qu'il a qu'il a porté
des valeurs importantes qu' a fait lui
aussi qui prend sa part dans cette
bataille culturelle que je juge
absolument fondamentale et donc je pense
que ce serait de mon point de vue c'est
mon point de vue personnel la meilleure
tête de liste possible et je je le
soutiens beaucoup dans ce combat voilà
courageux qu'il mène pour porter nos
valeurs en Europe et et vous le savez
nous faisons équipe pour la Fédération
des Yvelines vraiment et demain j'espère
que si je suis élu et bien nous pourrons
travailler ensemble en tout cas nous
avons choisi de faire équipe parce que
le travail qu'il fait en Europe le
travail que nous faisons national avec
la nouvelle direction des républicains
et le travail qu'on doit se faire dans
les Yvelines et bien pour moi c'est un
travail quand même du même ordre
c'est-à-dire assumer faire revivre une
droite qui porte clairement des messages
politiques avec des solutions pour le
pays vous pourriez être candidat sur la
liste européenne je ne me le destine pas
à cela je ne pas candidat je voilà ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui mon combat mon
combat c'est de continuer à essayer de
contribuer à à refonder la droite
d'abord dans mon département également
au national dans les médias parce que je
pense que c'est important de continuer à
le faire et puis de préparer les
échéances parce que ça va arriver très
vite notamment les municipales 2026 et
peut-être d'autres échéances qui vont
arriver je ce que je veux par contre
c'est qu'on fasse le meilleur résultat
possible aux européennes et j'espère
peut-être en tant que président de la
Fédération dans les ivelines en tout cas
que nous serons tous en ordre de marche
givvér pour pour faire en tout cas dans
les ivelines le meilleur score possible
alors je voudrais qu'on aborde un
problème d'actualité qui concerne le le
territoire national mais aussi les les
éines c'est ce le problème de
l'immigration euh dans dans une
interview très récente au parisiens euh
le le le président du groupe LR
l'assemblée dit ceci je ne voterai pas
un texte qui aggrave la situation de la
France ou qui fait semblant de changer
les chos avec cette loi géralde d'Anin
acte l'impuissance de la France
euh c'est c'est c'est c'est un propos
que vous reprendriez bien sûr il a
raison je l'ai déjà dit aussi oui oui
Olivier marlex a entièrement raison et
je je je je suis d'accord avec lui si on
fait un texte qui ne sert à rien et
qu'on donne à nouveau le sentiment qu'on
va essayer de régler un problème une
difficulté qu'en réalité on ne le fait
pas je suis désolé mais on nourrit la
défiance on nourrit l'abstention et on
nourrit là aussi tous ceux qui vont se
détourner des des parties comme le nôtre
qui sont censé être du côté des sol
solution parce qu'il faut arrêter de
faire semblant c'est là où je parler
d'une droite courageuse qui s'assure moi
je vais même plus loin je vous le dis
très clairement mais ericti l'a dit
aussi si le gouvernement tente de passer
en force par le 493 sur un texte un
mauvais texte notamment un texte qui
prévoit par exemple des régularisations
massives bien je suis désolé ça
m'intéresse votre point de vue sur la
régularisation justement vous êtes un
ancien élève d'achc vous connaissez bien
le monde de
l'entreprise la régularisation c'est en
effet des des gens qui enfin des
immigrés qui n' pas de statut enfin mais
qui travaillent qui on travaillent qui
sont pas qui qui n'ont pas de
condamnation qui sont utiles dans ce
qu'on appelle les secteurs en tension et
et je crois que le MF est d'ailleurs
favorable à la
régularisation pourquoi pourquoi c'est
un Chifou rouge pour le LR ça ben
d'abord parce que on parle d'un texte
qui est censé maîtriser les flux
migratoires et finalement un texte dont
les dispositions vont amené à ouvrir
davantage oui mais il y a des immig il y
a une immigration don on a besoin ou
alors attendez attendez on a eu 500000
arrivées légales l'année dernière c'est
un record historique absolu sans ces
nouvelles dispositions sans ce nouvel
appel d'air vous êtes en train de me
dire Patrice carmous qu'il faut qu'on
monte à 600 ou 700000 arrivé légal à ce
moment-là soyons pas d'aré c'est des
gens qui sont sur le territoire he oui
ben ils sont sur le territoire parce que
précisément ils ont pu arriver parfois
en situation légale et qu'ensuite ils se
sont retrouvés dans la clandestinité où
ils sont rentrés directement
illégalement mais si vous leur dites
demain que n'importe qui peut venir en
France ah oui c'est le sign question ég
mais bien sûr ça va créer évidemment un
appel d'airair incroyable et c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui parce que les
passeurs malheureusement qui exploitent
cette misère attention qui sont des
criminels qu'il faut combattre on est en
train de leur faire un formidable cadeau
on leur explique que quand on arrive en
France si on est expulsé bien on reste
quand même si la demande d'asile est est
refusée on reste quand même et même si
on vient et qu'on travaille dans un méti
ention on est certain de rester vous
croyez qu'il va se passer quoi à court
terme je suis désolé c'est irresponsable
et on va créer un nouvel appel d'air
alors qu'on a dans le même temps 500000
personnes de nationalité étrangère au
chômage 500000 donc si vous voulez si
vous voulez des des personnes étrangères
pour travailler dans certains métiers il
y en a déjà 500000 qui attendent un
emploi on a 1400000 jeunes dans notre
pays sans emploi sans formation et cette
idée pardon sordide qui consiste à
penser oui ah d'accord donc si je
comprends bien c'est des emplois qui
sont pas assez bons pour nous donc on va
laisser venir des gens qui vont rester
dans la clandestinité pendant peut-être
des années exploiter sans couverture
sociale sans charge sans rien sans
protection sociale on va les exploiter
et ensuite en leur disant mais vous en
faites pas vous serez régularisé après
pourquoi ben si ces secteurs sont en
tention c'est bien parce que il y a pas
il y a pas des gens qui qui sont qui
sont sans emploi qui veulent y aller je
suis bien d'accord et c'est pour cela
qu'il faut absolument que le travail
paye davantage qu'on a qu'on a un
problème d'assistana dans notre pays
qu'il y a trop de gens qui sont été
convaincus par l'idée qu'on pouvait
gagner sa vie en restant chez soi à
toucher l'échec de l'État ça a été le
fameux quoi qu'il en coûte je crois que
ce message a été terrible parce qu'il a
dévalorisé le travail il faut qu'on
revalorise le travail que ça paye
davantage on a un sujet de formation
dans ces métiers-l l'hôellerie la
restauration le BTP la sécurité
d'attractivité de ses métiers mais
arrêtons de dire sous prétexte que il y
a des gens qui sont aujourd'hui en
situation irrégulière qui vont avoir le
droit automatiquement à un titre de
séjour si on veut vraiment maîtriser les
flux migratoires ça devrait être
l'inverse et je vous invite à regarder
les textes déposés par les républicains
qui contiennent des dispositions
totalement opposées mais qui sont
cohérentes avec l'objectif politique qui
est affiché à savoir la maîtrise des
flux migratoires et aujourd'hui cet
article 3 et 4 ceux qui visent à la
régularisation automatique automatique
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
dans les méti anention c c rou et si le
gouvernement passe en force il faudra
qu'on fasse tomber le gouvernement il y
a rien de bien dans la loi votre
collègue Frédéric pchard policier hein
un grand policier dit il y a beaucoup de
bonnes choses dans cette loi il y a des
choses pas bien et puis il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de bonnes choses il il a donc
il il semble dire lui bon voilà on
pourrait peut-être trouver un accord non
mais la question est de savoir est-ce
que ce texte est de nature a changé
complètement les choses on a fait 20
textes sur l'immigration depuis 20 ans
20 textes français on l'impression que
Ch que vous disais tout à l'heure
c'estàd que voilà on a eu beaucoup de
mots très très forts sur l'immigration
mais peut-être que c'est un problème
beaucoup plus complexe à à régler qu'on
ne le pense et ça se règle pas comme ça
d'un coup de baguette magique oui mais
il faut qu'on trouve les bons outils
pour qu'on puisse décider en France qui
on veut accueillir et qui on veut
reconduire parce aujourd'hui nous ne
décidons pas qui on veut accueillirou
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
on y arrive pas c'est pour ça que à
droite on est convaincu qu'il faut une
révision constitutionnelle et un
référendum et si on veut réellement
reprendre les choses on peut toujours
avoir des petites dispositions qui vont
dans le bon sens mais si on veut
réellement reprendre la main et décider
qui on veut accueillir et qui on veut
reconduire avec par exemple des quotas
qui s'imposent on décide par métier par
F par par par pays d'origine qui on veut
accueillir une politique d'immigration
réellement choisie limitait aussi à ce
dont on a réellement besoin ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui où les les
dispositifs notamment d'asile ne sont
pas dévoyés ne sont pas détournés il
faut une révision constitutionnelle et
il faut un référendum autrement nous
faisons semblant c'est ça la réalité et
là aussi moi j'attends de ma famille
politique qu'elle dise honnêtement les
choses aux Français alors on est dans
une situation un peu bizarre puisque LR
se dirige peut-être vers la la motion de
censure et puis on parlera peut-être
après de savoir si c'est une bonne chose
pour elle s'il y avait une dissolution
mais et et en même temps on voit Marine
Le Pen qui dit bon finalement on va
peut-être voter la
loi écoutez je crois que Marine Le Pen
est vraiment servi par tous les excès de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est ce que je vous
disait c'est là où il y a un duo
absolument terrible c'est plus la France
insoumise montre son vrai visage plus
Marine Le Pen et bien joue et bien TRZ
pas du qu dro mais moi ça m'est
totalement égal la seule question c'est
on dit qu'on veut maîtriser les flux
migratoires est-ce que le texte qu'on a
sous la sur la table permet de le faire
s'il permet de le faire il faut le voter
s'il ne permet pas de le faire et
aujourd'hui le texte du Gouvernement ne
permet pas de le faire il faut si y
opposer c'est aussi simple que cela je
me moque totalement de savoir ce que va
faire Marine Le Pen qui a changé d'avis
sur ces sujetsl 1000 fois avant elle
parlerit d'immigration zéro elle n'en
parle plus elle parlait de sortir de
l'Europe elle n parle plus elle parlait
de sortir de l'euro qui sait où elle en
est donc moi je ne suis pas là pour être
le commentateur de de
de non ce qui me gêne c'est que
aujourd'hui on est un sentiment
d'impuissance publique ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'on soit toujours dans les mêmes
débats et que rien ne change en réalité
ce qui me gêne c'est que les nos
concitoyens on ont marre qu'on vient les
voir avant chaque élection pour leur
dire voilà ce qu'on va faire et
qu'ensuite il ne se passe rien et je
vous le dis j'applique cela aussi à la
droite je considère que on doit faire
notre inventaire et probablement qu'on a
déçu y compris sur ce sujet-l sur le
sujets régalien on n' pas été assez loin
et je crois que aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on ait le courage de le dire vous
voyez arrêtons de nous cacher derrière
notre petit doigt on veut des résultats
les Français ont le droit d'avoir des
solutions efficaces s'il y a pas de
révision constitutionnelle s'il y a pas
de référendum ce texte là mon av
changera pas c'est ce que vous souhaitez
hein et et justement il y a il y a une
petite musique puisqu'on arrive aux
élections européennes un peu
antieuropéennes sur ce discours sur
l'immigration c'estàdire que vous voulez
revenir sur un certain nombre de traités
euh vous voulez un référendum euh est-ce
que quand même euh bah une des des
missions de d'une d'une république ou
d'une démocratie c'est n'est pas de de
respecter bah les traités l'État de
droit tout en ayant une politique plus
ferme si on veut avoir une politique
plus ferme alors d'abord j'ai envie de
vous dire que ceux qui sont contre
l'Europe ce sont ceux qui ne veulent
rien changer parce que si on change rien
en Europe les peuples vont se détourner
de l'Europe c'est ce qui se passe dans
notre pays et même ce que dit quelqu'un
comme comme Jean-Louis bourlange qui pas
V qui est venu soutenir aussi dans les
ivelines qui pent cette idée là je pense
qu'il faut trouver l'équilibre compliqué
entre justement le respect de l'État de
droit et puis la volonté de l'opinion
quoi l'État de droit ça n'est pas de
rien changer l'état de droit il
s'aménage il change tout le temps alors
évidemment il faut trouver le bon
équilibre mais l'état de droit il se
change et quel est cet État de droit qui
fait qu'on ne peut pas décider qui on
veut accueillir et qui on veut
reconduire comment voulez-vous que les
gens l'acceptent ils vont choisir de
sortir de l'Europe si on leur propose
pas une Europe qui en capacité de leur
permettre d'assumer leur souveraineté en
la matière je veux dire il y a aucun
traité européen en matière migratoire
qui empêche normalement un pays de
décider qui veut accueillir et qui veut
reconduire et pardon de vous dire
Patrice carmos que nous nous attaquons
pas au traité nous nous attaquons à des
jurisprudences à des interprétation de
certains juges des traités son parfis
exactement dans des interprétations qui
sont parfois très idéologi
et je suis désolé il faut qu'one efftiv
cette révision constitionnelle et
référendum pour qu'on échappe à ces
jurisprudences on vous parle pas de
sortir des traités les traités quand on
les lit ils ne disent pas du tout ce que
disent certains juges qui nous empêchent
aujourd'hui d'avoir une politique
migratoire assumer et si nous ne le
faisons pas comme le veulent tous ces
EUR B qui ne veulent rien changer et
bien je vous le dis les Français vont se
détourner de l'Europe et moi je ne le
veut pas parce que je pense qu'on a
besoin d'une construction européenne
mais pas celleel quand Olivier Barle par
faut qu'on revienne l'état originel de
ce qui était Schengen et l'état originel
de ce qui était Schengen c'est qu'il y
avait les Grecs les Italiens et les
Espagnols qui se qui qui se coltinent au
problème de l'immigration puisqu'ils
étaient ils avaient des ils avaient la
Méditerranée et puis je sais pas les les
les les les pays polonais tout ça ne
faisait rien là on a changé les choses
de façon à ce que bah toute l'Europe
prenne sa part c'est pas mieux quand
même oui mais quand on veut financer des
des infrastructures de sécurité ou de
protection des frontières dans ces pays
limitropes qui effectivement reçoivent
tout le flux il faut les aider bien sûr
François Xavier bami porte cette idée là
et les eurodéputés macronistes votent
contre parce qu'ils ont un discours ici
dans notre pays avec Monsieur darmanal
et ils ont un autre discours au
Parlement européen et c'est le drame de
ça en même temps qui a conduit le pays
dans une impasse qui a conduit le pays
au chaos parce qu'on nous avait dit que
c'était où Emmanuel Macron ou le chaos
mais finalement on a Emmanuel Macron et
le chaos il faut arrêter ces ambiguïtés
là il faut arrêter d'avoir deux visages
il faut arrêter d'avoir des
positionnements purement tactiques oui
vous avez raison il faut qu'on aide les
pays évidemment qui reçoivent l'ESS du
flux à aménager les choses mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut assumer de dire qu'il
faut aussi qu'on puisse décider qui on
veut accueillir et qu' on veut pas
reconduire que quelqu'un dans la demande
d'asile est rejeté ne peut pas rester
sinon ça ne peut pas marcher et
aujourd'hui ça ne marche plus justement
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites que
qui on peut accueillir qui on peut pas
accueillir au fond est-ce que l'une des
difficultés de la France à traiter cette
question de l'immigration c'est pas d'en
avoir fait une question passionnelle
alors que c'est une question technique
presque B vous avez raison parce que dès
qu'on aborde ce sujet-l on est tout de
suite taxé ou ou de
r bien sûr bien sûr alors que alors que
tout le monde comprend qu'aucun pay au
monde laiss passer tout le monde et c
bien sûr alors qu'aucun pays oui mais
pardon c'est souvent une accusation de
la gauche dès qu'on ce thème là c'est
rarement la gauche de chqu politique on
nous dit mais non mais oui c'est
rarement la gauche qui nous dit faut
faut faire quelque chose sur
l'immigration par contre dès qu'on veut
faire quelque chose discours de je sais
pas ou qui ont été critiqué par leur
camp d'ailleurs à l'époque et même
récemment ce que je veux vous dire
simplement c'est que n'importe quel pays
a le droit de choisir qui veut
accueillir et de reconduire ceux qui
n'ont rien à faire là qu'un étranger qui
par exemple se rend coupable d'un crime
ou d'un délit et bien ne soit pas
automatiquement expulsé à l'issue de sa
peine ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
entendable parce que évid faut-il
trouver le pays vers lequel l'expulser
qui n' veut généralement pas bien sûr
vous avez raison il y a des difficultés
en des difficultés quand même enfin
voilà dans les jurisprudences dont on
parlait tout c'est pour ça qu'ut faut
peut-être pas simplifier trop enfin
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué c'est un
problème complexe et technique à mon
avis mais il y aussi un sujet de volonté
politique et je n'ai pas le sentiment
que chez Emmanuel Macron sur ces sujetsl
de l'immigration mais de la du régalien
de la sécurité en général j'ai pas le
sentiment qu'il y ait une grande volonté
politique en tout cas je ne l'ai pas vu
un mot un mot sur sur sur vous vous êtes
vous êtes né au Maroc à Casablanca vous
êtes arrivé en France quoi vous aviez
dit tout à fait pour pour pour intégrer
les les les classes préparatoires c'est
ça à versaill he oui tout à fait
qu'est-ce qui reste en vous de votre
enfance alors c'est intéressant que vous
me posiez cette question Patrice Camous
par que certains me disent parfois sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment
effectivement toujours certains certains
comptes anonymes de la France insoumise
m'attaque en me disant mais voyez il ve
maîtriser les fluts migratoires mais il
est lui-même issu de l'immigration mais
précisément précisément moi je souhaite
que évidemment les gens puissent et bien
venir régulièrement en France pour
étudier je je suis venu comme un
étudiant être naturalisé s'il
remplissent les critères s'ils font
preuve de leur assimilation et cetera
mais euh il y a aucun immigré aucun
enfant issu de l'immigration aucune
personne qui aime sincèrement la France
qui a envie que n'importe qui puisse
venir dans n'importe quelle circonstance
et rester quoi qu'il fasse et quel que
soit son comportement ça ne marche nulle
part et donc je me sens aussi une
responsabilité pour dire précisément que
avec mon histoire particulière j'assume
de dire que ce pays a une culture qu'il
faut s'approprier des règles qu'il faut
s'approprier des lois qu'il faut
respecter et bien sûr qu'il faut donner
sa chance à chacun à partir du moment où
ces conditions sont remplies c'est pour
ça que je vous dis il faut choisir qui
on veut accueillir et il faut et bien
reconduire ceux qui n'ont rien à faire
en France et
donc moi j'assume j'assume totalement ce
discours là qui au contraire me donne je
pense une responsabilité sur tous ces
sujetsl que je connais particulièrement
bien vous avez la double nationalité
alors moi je suis N au Maroc je suis né
je suis né marocain et ensuite seulement
j'ai été naturalisé je suis devenu
français euh voilà et j'ai j'ai choisi
évidemment de de de de de de consacrer
tout mon engagement à ce pays qui m'a
beaucoup donné vous savez moi il y a 10
ans il y a un peu plus il y a 15 ans
j'étais un étudiant je ne connaissais
personne dans le monde politique je
venais d'être naturalisé et j'ai eu la
chance de faire le parcours que j'ai pu
faire pas me dire que c'est pas possible
VI pas me dire que ce n'est pas possible
qu'on vienne pas me dire qu'on est dans
un pays là aussi structurellement
raciste je suis vice-président de la
Région îdefance depuis maintenant 8 ans
dans ma famille personne n'était
français personne ne faisait de
politique donc vous voyez que c'est ce
modèle là que je veux défendre ça
suppose aussi d'être capable d'un
discours de fermeté et d'assumer
certaines convictions vous un très
prantélèv au Maroc non euh moi j'ai
toujours été un bon j'ai grandi dans une
famille où on considérait que les études
c'étaaiit important et que l'effort
était récompensé moi j'ai des parents
qui m'ont toujours dit qu'en France et
bien quand on quand on étudie on réussi
voilà donc j'ai passé mes concours euh
j'ai j'ai intégré donc à CHUS comme je
suis attché aux yvelin aussi j'ai fait
mes classes pré à
versaill aujourd'hui 50 ans Yveline et
puis après vous vous entrez assez vite
en politique quand même juste après la
chaussée quoi euh oui oui alors j'étais
président du bureau des étudiants d'
chaussée j'ai été élu à cette
responsabilité là et donc j'éis déjà
natural très engagé et j'étais à la fois
préoccupé déjà de de de la tournure des
choses en France et je me sentais que je
devais rendre un peu ce que ce pays m'a
donné alors j'ai d'abord créé une
entreprise dans le logiciel que j'ai
revendu que j'ai revendu et maintenant
je me consacre à mes à mes à cet
engagement politique mais mais en
l'occurrence j'ai toujours pensé qu'il
fallait effectivement qu'on s'engage
parce que les choses ne se font jamais
d'elle-même 2014 à peu près hein 2012
engagement ma première élection c'est
2014 trpe première campagne grâce à
laquelle on fait basculer 50 an yeline
avec évidemment tous les maires de
toutes les villes de droite et pourquoi
le choix de la droite alors parce que je
crois au mérite à la responsabilité
individuelle je crois que on ne
construit rien sur le désordre je crois
que cette idée absurde que l'argent
public pousse sur les arbres et que on
va continuer à financer un modèle social
toujours plus généreux alors qu'on ne
produit plus suffisamment je pense que
ce sont des grandes démagogies et que la
gauche a beaucoup imposé ces thème
pendant longtemps et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une droite
qui est en capacité de mener cette
bataille culturelle je n'ai jamais
regretté mon engagement à droite quel
qui pu être les difficultés VO moi je
suis fidèle j'ai jamais quitté ma
famille politique mais parce que je
pense que le pays a besoin et bien de ce
discours là et de ces solutions là alors
on va pour terminer montrer quelques
photos et puis vous allez alors il y a
deux ou trois photos et vous vous
choisissez ben ù ù quoi hein vous
m'inquiétez Patrice regardez alors on va
commencer par une première photo c'est
c'est voilà alors il y a il y a trap et
puis il y a le conseil régional c'est
les alors je va pas je vais choisir
faement je vais choisir Trapp et vous
savez pourquoi parce que ce que vous
avez là c'est l'ancien siège du Conseil
régional puisque maintenant nous sommes
à saintto je ne peux pas
choisir parce que vous le savez avec
Valérie PC on a déménagé ou ou siège
nous coûtait très cher et on a déménagé
en dehors de Paris on est en sainttoin
effectivement fait une grande économie
là-dessus et puis trap m'a énormément
appris c'est une ville à laquelle je
seraai toujours attaché parce que j'ai
fait mes armes que j'ai beaucoup appris
j'ai pris beaucoup de coup aussi mais ça
fait partie aussi d'un engagement
politique et je suis fier de pouvoir
dire que j'ai toujours tenu le même
discours celui que je vous tiens là qui
est le même que celui que j'ai toujours
tenu à trappe quel qu' pu être les
difficultés deuxème photo allez ah
Pierre Bédier Valérie P alors Pierre
Bédier à qui vous allez peut-être
succéder et et Valérie PCR qui qui vous
a nommé enfin avec qui dont vous êtes
très proche quoi vous êtes taquin
Patrice carmou non mais écoutez évidment
je travaille au
quodien je travaille au quotidien avec
Valérie depuis maintenant presque 10 ans
elle a été une des premières à
m'accorder sa confiance et voilà donc
évidemment je TR avec elle au quotidien
mais je veux vous dire vraiment et en
faisant cette candidature j'ai été voir
évitamment Pierre Bédier je lui ai écrit
aussi je ne suis candidat contre
personne voilà je pense qu'on meurt des
divisions stériles des guerres du passé
qu'on a plus les moyens de se diviser
dans notre état de faiblesse et donc
vous n'aurez pas de ma part la moindre
attaque personnelle la moindre polémique
stérile jusqu'au bout de cette élection
parce que non parce que demain il faudra
reconstruire tout ça et par contre je
suis déterminé à le faire dans la clarté
des convictions ça ça me paraî important
une autre photo allez une dernière ah
oui de deux personnalités des ielin il y
a brun pivé qui est président de
l'Assemblée et hauror berger qui est
ministre depuis quelques quelques mois
je sais pas quoi vous dire j'ai pas
vocation à arbitrer entre des
personnalités qui sont pas de ma famille
politique je vais quand même choisir la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
parce que au moins euh Aurore berger
était chez nous elle est partie et je
comprends qu'on puisse partir mais je
trouve que les gens qui ont une
rectitude dans les idées qui assument la
droiture à ma connaissance elbron pivé
n'a pas varié même si j'ai avec elle
énormément de divergen bien au moins je
veux saluer de manière républicaine et
surtout le fait qu'elle subisse des
attaques je veux le dire absolument
terrible notamment depuis son
déplacement en Israël je trouve que
voilà il faut faut défendre c'est pour
ça que je la cite on a quelques autres
photos
allez he ah ah oui alors non mais
Patrice carmous je vais vous dire une
chose là-dessus le piège dans lequel on
essaie de nous enferm c'est précisément
d'avoir à choisir alors que nous avions
vocation à défendre nos propres idées
donc je vais faire quelque chose sur ce
plateau qui peut-être va choquer du
monde je ne choisirai pas sur cette
photo làà parce que moi mon objectif
c'est qu'à droite on soit présent demain
et bien au même niveau de popularité au
même niveau d'affiche mais je veux vous
dire que je tiens Emmanuel Macron pour
responsable de la situation du pays et
pour responsable y compris du score de
Marine Le Pen qui l'a installé comme
seule alternative donc il y a un moment
l'histoire du barrage républicain si les
Digon céd c'est parce qu'il y a des gens
qui par cyisme on en fait un instrument
électoral et moi je pense que
culpabiliser les électeurs et donner des
consignes de vote ça ne marche plus ça
ne marche jamais la dernière élection
présidentielle l'a prouver je pense
qu'on a besoin d'une droite et bien qui
sorte un peu de cette tyrannie qu'on
essaie de nous imposer en nous forçant à
choisir un camp moi le camp mon camp mon
seul camp ça a toujours été la droite et
ça le sera jusqu'au bout alors bon
continue alleer encore une ou deux
photos
ah justement vous voulez pas me mettre
des gens de des républicains on a des
talents famille politique si j'ur pu
vous demander Laurent vquier ou David
dis par exemple voà non mais au moins
vous me mettez au moins des deux
làdedans parce que là non parce que
c'est possible qu'un de ces trois soit
le candidat un peu de la droite en 2027
non ça n'est pas possible non ça n'est
pas possible Monsieur Philippe que je
respecte il a signé les décrets de
fermeture de fenhe on parlait nucléaire
de tout à l'heure donc il faudra quand
même m'expliquer comment on peut être le
candidat de la droite quand on a soutenu
accepter avaliser des décisions aussi
contraires à l'intérêt du pays et aussi
contraire à ce qu'on pensait à ce qu'on
pense à droite je pense que monsieur
darmana a malheureusement un très
mauvais bilan en tant que ministre de
l'Intérieur je pense que Monsieur le
Maire est le le le responsable de ce
chéquier en bois massif qui est
aujourd'hui dans les mains de l'État à
force de de de multiplier les dépenses
publiques je ils ont tous accepté le SI
le le le le quoi qu'il en coûte pendant
la crise du covid mais le problème c'est
que le quoi qu'il en coûte a coûté
beaucoup plus cher que dans d'autres
pays et qu'il ne s'est jamais arrêté il
ne s'est jamais arrêté entreprise Mo il
y quand même des résultats non mais
d'accord mais les Allemands aussi ont
fait quoi qu'il en coûte qui leur a
coûté trois fois moins cher et puis
pardon à côté de ça il y a jamais eu de
réformes structurelles jamais l'État n'a
fait d'économie on a le record des
dépenses publiques le record des
prélèvements obligatoires et le record
de la dette donc ça veut dire que ce
pays aujourd'hui n'est plus géré comme
il le faut et Bruno le merire porte une
lourde responsabilité là-dessus ils ont
tous accepté de siéger au au côté d'Éric
Dupont moriti qui est pas vraiment de
droite de papendia qui ne portait pas
vraiment une politique d'éducation
nationale de droite comme on l'aimerait
par en même temps non oui mais le en
même temps nous a coûté cher à ce pays
ils en sont tous complices allez une
dernière photo pour la route ah c'est
Dupont ou Mbappé c'est le rugby le
football non mais je vais choisir le
rugby je vais choisir le rugby parce que
j'aime bien les valeurs qui sont
véhiculées et puis attendez on vient de
sortir de la Coupe du monde donc je veux
dire c'est le moment où jamais ça s'est
bien passé oui ça s'est bien passé
ouioup la Coupe du monde de rugby donc
allez pour le geste et pour le sport le
rugby
merci je rappelle donc l'élection enfin
ça ne concerne que les que les adhérents
à jour de cotisation de LR auront lieu
les 26 et 27 novembre prochain merci
merci beaucoup
merci